i keep reading and i don't i don't know
all of it you can explain it to me that
you're out at sunday night football
that's the end and this other dude is
taking over why if you're the number one
guy you do such a great job
is it your age what is going on at nbc
that they don't want you for sunday
night football well i wouldn't say they
don't want me for sunday night football
but what happened was a few years ago i
signed a contract
and
you need a successor
uh and bob costas retired from the
olympics and nbc and they brought mike
to rico into
to take that over and mike had done
monday night football in the years after
i had done monday football so
at a certain point you have to have a
succession plan i understand that my you
know contract is ending it doesn't mean
i'm not going to be a part of nbc that
that that's still possibly
in the cards it's one of the things
that's being talked about right now um i
think it's a matter of somebody said to
me
it's crazy and you're talking about the
age thing uh i guess in in the
prevalence of football i've out-kicked
the coverage it's like at a certain
point
you should be done
but i'm sorry i helped screw this thing
up i think by you know not being done
and
at least in my in my mind i'm not done
so i love doing this i i don't know
what's going to happen it's a weird time
in the in the business all of these new
deals have been signed amazon has a new
deal uh espn and and disney and abc have
a
an extended deal
so everything is is
kind of in play right now
and i vowed before this season
that i wanted to enjoy this season to
the nth degree and
i have and to get distracted by stuff on
the side
uh i didn't want that to happen right so
i'll do the super bowl on sunday and
then next week i can begin to have some
clarity of thought and think about what
it is what's the best
position for me the best option for me
the best opportunity for me if it's out
there so the current deal you have with
nbc expires after the super bowl you're
a free agent right correct and you
probably know right now in your heart
where you're going you already have a
pretty good idea what the money offer is
on the table you're just laying low
until the broadcast is over no you're
right but i don't know
what i'm going to do you know it's i'm
not just um
the lone ranger here when you do a a
show or you sign on to do a show
you need the right people around you
to make that show work
so i'm gonna i can't be thrown into a
situation where i'm working with anybody
i mean let's face it robin's made this
show all these years
absolutely
i say that with all seriousness i i
don't want to why anyone else would [ __ ]
me up i've i've worked with other people
i right robin's uh my person so i get
that and the same reason
that you left a broadcast because madden
left the broadcast many years ago right
and that was point when that's when
disney took monday night and moved it
from
abc over the air
to
espn and they took my producer fred
godelli they think my director drew
essekoff still my guys
madden some of the other people that are
very important behind the scenes and i'm
the guy who stuck out here doing this
thing with a whole bunch of other people
not that they wouldn't be good or
weren't good but i was just wait a
second i had just done 20 years with
most of these people and i needed to
continue so i needed to make that move
over to nbc right and now it's been you
know it's been 16 years on sunday night
football which has become you know the
number one show on television
jeff bezos is listening this morning
what do you want to say to jeff about
money and uh just not running the
company he's not even going to talk to
jeff i don't think well i don't know
the only thing the only thing i'll tell
jeff is i'm not going up in that rocket
ship unless you put me in first class